okay faced in the book that inspired a
million crying girls Tumblr posts comes
the romance that did for cancer what
while I did for vampires The Fault in
Our Stars ride along for a touching
story about how one girl's cancer led to
fun sex and extravagant European
vacations but instead of sugarcoating
the truth get ready for two well-rounded
characters with a powerful message
everyone you love will die meet hazel
and her sidekick luggage she's a smart
young girl who's more than just a cancer
survivor she's also a total downer
depression is not as that effective
cancer it's a side effect of dying I
just sort of say that you know there's
gonna come a time when all of us are
dead
knowing you just die
things sighs Hazel's world will
transform when she attends the most
adorable Cancer Support Group ever there
she'll meet fellow survivor Augustus
waters a confident six-foot-four
well-spoken adorkable polite funny star
athlete philosopher poet with a six-pack
and probably by full version ah sure you
are together they'll bond over a book
with a title just as pretentious as The
Fault in Our Stars an imperial
affliction and their shared habit of
talking like really weird old people
your daughter she's done a great
injustice you have no idea how utterly
impressed them that you are I am in the
midst of a grand soliloquy here welcome
to the sweet torture of reading an
imperial affliction Kim what's a teapot
but you don't take part
follow Gus's heroic struggle to get into
a dying girl's pants a struggle so
difficult he has to read her favorite
book pain demands to be felt your
quarter my buck score her a meeting with
this reclusive author and exploit a
cancer charity to send them on a dream
vacation just to get out of the
friendzone
from friends you earned it pal
say okay to a pg-13 film that glorifies
underage drinking and pasting the stops
life-threatening sex
and making out in the room where Anne
Frank was abducted with no consideration
for the people who came there to honor
the Holocaust not sure that warrants a
slow clap but
okay so cuddle up for a beautiful finale
where our straw cross lovers have a
moment of true happiness together before
everything goes to hell it is featuring
tough to watch medical emergencies
heartbreaking hospital visits a close
friend going blind
a close friend getting dunked just for
going blind with [ __ ] Willem Dafoe
being a drink crushing dick I want you
to leave teenagers with cancer attending
their own practice funeral real funerals
and four different eulogies within the
numbered days and for that I am
eternally Curt enough it's too sad story
go starring
oh that's Angela he's so hot right now
sick McLovin Jurassic mom that guy who
showed his fight a lot on True Blood
douche pants and tears cancer king sucks
you put the thing that does the killing
right between your teeth but you never
give it the power to kill you
he totally stole that from getting jiggy
with it be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers
I gotta find boba bubbles fluffy cheese
waffles round one fight I'm have deep
voice for no reason